nous voilà en pleine saison des impôts
si ce n'est pas l'étape la plus
réjouissante de l'année pour plusieurs
d'entre nous une étude récente démontre
que les contribuables entretiennent
souvent bien malgré eux une foule
d'idées reçues sur notre système
d'imposition ses raisons d'être et ses
effets sur nos portefeuilles
qui de mieux que notre collègue gérald
fillion pour dissiper la confusion qui
règne
gerald quel plaisir d'être ici chez vous
quelque sorte oui car mon grand studio
bienvenus merci beaucoup
débout le nom d'amy intrus qui circulent
souvent l'état prend la moitié de mon
salaire qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ce
genre d'affirmation mais si vous faites
au moins sept cent quarante mille
dollars par année
oui l'état prend la moitié de votre
salaire qui mais dans les faits l'état
ne prend pas la moitié de votre salaire
parce qu'il ya différents paliers
d'imposition
un exemple pour une personne qui fait
cinquante mille dollars par année
vous avez un taux fédéral de 17% vous
avez un tour du québec à 20%
donc ça fait 37 % c'est cet homme
marginal
c'est le taux rendent à 50000 vous vous
payez 37 % d'impôts mais le vrai tout
effectifs étant donné que vous payez pas
d'impôts sur les premiers 12 13 mille
dollars de revenus et que les taux
d'imposition sont plus faibles en bottes
45 1000 par année
votre vrai taux effectif et de 21% à
partir de 210 mille dollars par exemple
vous allez faire vous allez avoir un
taux d'imposition de 53%
mais c'est encore une fois le taux
marginal parce que le vrai taux sur
l'ensemble de vos revenus pour vous
rendre à 210 mille dollars le taux
effectif
le taux effectif il est plus boyle et
autour de 40%
tomas j naldo effectif en russie on
retient sa autre élément qui revient
souvent
j'ai moins de revenus donc je n'ai pas
besoin de faire de déclaration d'impôts
c'est faux vous devez faire une
déclaration d'impôts si vous ne faites
pas une déclaration de revenus même si
vous avez pas beaucoup de revenus ou
très très peu ou pas de revenus du tout
mais vous allez vous priver de
prestations disposer contre-productif et
de crédit d'impôt c'est tout à fait
contre productif alors il ya des
allocations familiales
il ya des crédits d'impôt remboursables
qui est dit n'est pas remboursable ça
veut dire qu'on vous
une le crédit d'impôt même si vous payez
pas d'impôts mais pour ça vous devez
absolument faire une déclaration de
revenus pour avoir droit tous les
remboursements
prestations crédits d'impôt très bien
autre affirmation qu'on voit souvent
j'augmente en revenus alors donc ça veut
dire nécessairement des certaines
personnes que je vais changer de tranche
d'imposition et perdre finalement les
avantages qui amène la bonne notation de
salaire ben c'est pas vrai il ya
certainement des bénéfices a augmenté de
salaire même si vous avez une faible
augmentation de salaire généralement il
va vous restez un gain mais il ya
surtout au québec ce qu'on appelle un
bouclier fiscal vous avez une hausse de
salaire donc vous touchez plus de
revenus alors le crédit pour la prime au
travail ou le crédit pour frais de garde
par exemple sur abc là vous allez dire
non mais je perds
non vous perdez pas parce que le
bouclier fiscal est un autre crédit
d'impôt qui vient compenser une partie
de la perte de revenus
ça a été pensé parce qu'effectivement ne
constater au fil du temps que si vous
augmentez de quelques milliers de
dollars puis vous tombez dans l'autre
tranche d'impôt vous perdez une bonne
partie de votre gain ce bouclier fiscal
a été instaurée précisément pour éviter
cette situation sont bien pensées quand
même oui l'autre mythe convoi
déboulonner ensemble gérald et 510 toute
impasse que je le vois pas assez souvent
la moitié des gens de paix poney ben
c'est pas vrai on dit souvent même au
québec c'est davantage vrai qu ailleurs
essono plus c'est pas vrai il voyait
2006 à faire tomber le premier c'est que
le québec n'est pas pire que les eaux au
québec
36% des contribuables ne paie pas
d'impôt en ontario 6 34 % en alberta
s'est plus élevé 39 pour ses sketchs
owens et 42%
ils ne paient pas d'impôts ces gens là
tout simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas
les moyens de payer des impôts au québec
33 % des contribuables gagnant moins de
20 milles de là par annick terme c'est
c'est le tiers des gens c'est quand même
beaucoup de gens qui gagnent pas
beaucoup d'argent et qui une fois après
avoir reçu différentes déduction ne paie
pas du tout d'impôts merci beaucoup
gerald merci beaucoup à une prochaine
mes potes à coeur a pas mieux ben oui
au delà du bief des fausses croyances
on doit aussi se méfie des techniques de
hameçonnage basé sur l'impôt ça vous dit
quelque chose
est-ce que ça fait déjà arrivé de
recevoir un texto ou un appel ou un
outil ici l' agence du revenu
je pense que ça arrive a tellement
répondrez vous faites pour les
reconnaître fait que ça arrive par texto
par courriel c'est pas normal
l'orthographe une agence de revenus en
répondent et textos en excursion puisque
je dois envoyer des cartes itunes
seulement ces agences est en voie de
l'être c'est ce que l'adresse courriel
qui c'est un courriel adressé légitime
si je suis certain je te défends d'un
visionnement il ya des gens qui se font
passer pour des organismes
gouvernementaux pour soutirer des
données personnelles
oui c'est quelque chose qu'on voit très
souvent et qu'on voit même à l'année
longue même hors saison d'impôts donc
des gens qui se font passer soit pour l'
agence du revenu du canada vous pour le
ministère du revenu au québec et qui
vont envoyer soit des courriels ou de
plus en plus des textos en disant voici
vous avez reçu un remboursement d'impôt
de tels montants pour l'encaisser
cliquer sur le lien et évidemment ce
sont des tentatives de hameçonnage c'est
à dire que quand on clique sur signé là
on essaie de me soutirer vos données
personnelles nom adresse numéro
d'assurance sociale numéro de carte de
crédit
mais c'est pas de cette façon là que le
gouvernement nous fait naître
remboursement d'impôt claude hauret
nouvelle
non c'est sympa par virement direct dont
ces germes en chef le soir où ça va être
un dépôt direct parce qu'on aurait déjà
envoyé nos données donc si on lui
demande de cliquer sur un lien pour
recevoir notre remboursement à éviter de
cliquer sur ce lien et il paraît même
que des fraudeurs boucherie qui laisse
miroiter la possibilité de payer ses
impôts par le biais de cartes cadeaux
c'est bref comment ça marche
c'est pas une méthode utilisée par le
gouvernement pour encaisser les impôts
mais des fraudeurs s'essaye donc ils
vont écrire à des contribuables et leur
dire vous devez pas vivre votre impôt en
allant
acheter une carte cadeau d'un magasin en
ligne par exemple ils vont dire acheter
une carte cadeau de 200 dollars et puis
envoyez nous le code d'activation pour
utiliser le montant sur la carte cadeau
ici comme ça que vous allez payer vos
impôts donc c'est complètement farfelu
des gens peuvent se faire prendre
évidemment c'est une fois qu'on a envoyé
l'argent une fois qu'on a acheté la
carte cadeau et qu'on envoyer le code
ça devient plus difficile de récupérer
son argent quel bon vieux téléphone
aussi il ya des méthodes d'hameçonnage
qui passent par ce moyen là un peu plus
archaïque mais qui fait des victimes
quand même oui donc peut-être alexis que
tous déjà reçu un message de la boîte
vocale un peu menaçants automatisé qui
dit vous devez rappeler à tel numéro
sinon mandats d'arrêt vont être émis
contre vous mais sa brutale qui étend la
première fois ce message là et qu'on
nous dit que la police va venir à notre
porte
on peut être tenté de rappeler le plus
vite possible à ce numéro là mais si
souvent des numéros qui vont être payant
par exemple des numéros 1 900 donc on
appelle et puis ça nous facture montant
d'argent sur notre facture de téléphonie
cellulaire ou notre facture de téléphone
quand on appelle ces numéros là encore
une fois on peut essayer de nous
soutirer des informations personnelles
donc si on rappelle la personne au bout
du fil va souvent être menaçante avoir
insisté pour qu'on donne le plus vite
possible nous donner encore une fois
sous la menace d'une arrestation
mais les gens peuvent se rassurer le
gouvernement du canada les gouvernements
provinciaux ne procède pas de cette
façon-là
quand on leur doit de l'impôt il n'y a
pas d'appel de menacer le mandat d'arrêt
que son ennemi et encode d'autres c'est
vraiment le de rappeler le numéro
officiel de l'agencé du revenu
et si on pense avoir été victime d'une
tentative de fraude d'appeler le centre
antifraude du canada
tout ça qui existe à notre portée toutes
ses ressources il faut en profiter et de
dénoncer ces gens là qui risque de faire
des victimes d'année en année oui ça
c'est vrai c'est important a rappelé